Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain an American mystery adventure television
series called “The Mysterious Benedict
Society”. Watch out and take care!
The premise of the movie is set far in the
future. Our world is secretly being attacked
by a mysterious force that is making people
more anxious everyday. Because of the anxiety,
the illusion of international panic known as "The
Emergency" is created. It has induced citizens
with a fear of something bad happening
which in turn, messes with the economy,
and other factors plaguing the world.
Reynie is an orphan who loves to read and
enjoys his own company. He wants to make friends
but the children in the orphanage make fun of him
for being intelligent. He often feels out of
place, mostly because the others aren’t half
as smart as him. His only mentor is his Tamil
language teacher, Ms. Perumal. One day, she
shows him an advertisement about a test, in which
the winners are awarded a scholarship to attend a
prestigious school called the Boatwright Academy.
Reynie has always wanted to go to Boatwright
but he doubts his abilities. Ms. Peruman
assures him that he will be the most deserving
one out of all the attendees of the test.
The next morning, she comes to pick him up. Then,
they drive to the examination hall and separate
after a hug. Many children alongside him have come
to take the test. Their examiner is named Number
Two, a quirky but strict woman who briefs them on
what they can and cannot do. Reynie looks at the
first question which asks him, if he has a chance
to save only one between an elephant and a llama
falling from a height, who would he save. Reynie
answers that he would save the elephant in hopes
that it could break the llama’s fall and both of
them would survive. After answering several such
questions with answers related to compassion,
he reaches the last one that asks him if he
is brave. Reynie takes time to think about
it and answers that he would like to think so.
Number two asks them to drop their pencils.
She grades the papers as the students
wait patiently. After getting done, she
informs them that the students who pass this
test will be admitted to the second phase
of the exam. They should report to a
building in the next block at exactly 1 pm.
She also emphasizes that they are only allowed to
bring a single pencil and eraser to the test. When
Reynie asks her if they will be provided with
sharpeners in case the lead breaks, she answers
that they will have everything necessary for the
test. Then, she reads the list of students who
passed that has only Reynie’s name on it. Everyone
else disappointedly leaves the premises while
Reynie goes to the next examination hall.
While walking inside, a girl before him named
Rhonda accidentally drops her pencil into a
sewer drain. Ronda’s friend abandons her and
walks inside but, Reynie offers to help her. They
only have a few minutes before the exam starts,
so he breaks his pencil into two and hands
one to her, confident that a sharpener will
be provided inside. She expresses gratitude and
offers to show him the answers during the test
but Reynie declines the offer. In the examination
hall, Number two explains to them that anyone who
speaks during the test will be dismissed. She also
adds that the test will be long and difficult. A
girl groans at the comment and is disqualified for
making noise. Reynie raises his hand and gestures
that he needs to sharpen his pencil. Number
two understands and allows him to do so.
The test finally starts and only a few seconds in,
a boy runs away shouting that he cannot do this.
Reynie focuses on the questions which
are too difficult for him to understand.
Most of them are advanced-level questions about
world history and geography. Still, Rhonda,
who is seated right before Reynie, gets done in
only half an hour. Before submitting the answers,
she secretly drops a small piece of paper for
Reynie. He notices the paper has all the answers
on it. Although Reynie is struggling with the
questions, he doesn’t pick it up. The atmosphere
is intense as some students almost cry because
of the difficult questions. Reynie knows none
of the answers but on reading the questions
carefully, he realizes that the answer to the
first question is hidden in the last question.
That way, all the answers are in the questions
themselves. After finding that out, he easily
writes them down and does great on the test.
A while later, the result is announced and again,
only Reynie passes. It is surprising to him
because Rhonda has cheated. She wishes him luck
and leaves him to wait for further instruction.
Then, an A grade student named Sticky Washington
enters the room. Sticky has an eidetic memory,
meaning he can remember everything he sets his
eyes on. He was also the only one who passed the
test in his batch which he thinks is weird
because someone else had cheated. It turns
out that they had the same experience before the
test and met the same girl who dropped her pencil
in the sewage. They figure out the actual aim of
the trick was to test their loyalty and kindness.
Therefore, they passed and the other students
who only focused on the questions, didn’t.
Suddenly, a girl comes running to the room and
introduces herself as Kate. She is an athletic
and adventurous girl who never goes anywhere
without her red bucket of tools. Kate claims
that she didn’t actually pass the test because
the questions were too difficult. Infact, she was
selected because she helped Number two chase away
all the angry parents by creating a distraction.
Then, Krista and Dewey join the group. They have
also passed the exam and are pretty confident
that they will make it to the Boatwright
Academy. Krista is a know-it-all who thinks
that everyone is inferior to her. After the team
has assembled, they are introduced to Milligan,
the overseer of the next test. He instructs
them to enter a room one after another,
and asks Krista to go first.
She walks into the room and notices the
chessboard patterned floor. A note on the floor
asks her to cross the room without stepping on
the black or white squares. She bluntly
says no, refusing to do the task because
she thinks it is a trick question. Milligan
disqualifies her and asks her to go home.
Next, Dewey enters the room and uses his
athletic abilities to jump to the yellow squares.
He sticks to the wall, and leaps to the other
end of the room easily. After he passes,
Kate enters with her red buckets of tools.
She uses a rope from her bucket and ties it
tightly to make a pathway. Kate used to work in
a circus for a long time and can easily walk on
ropes. She uses her skills to reach the other end
and complete the task. When it is Sticky’s turn,
he reads the question carefully and figures
out that it specifically asks them to not step
with their feet. So, he instead gets on all four
and crosses the room. Lastly, Reynie thinks for
a long time and simply walks to the other end
of the room. When asked how he passed the test,
he claims that the boxes had longer lengths,
which means that they weren’t squares. Since
the question asked them not to step on the
squares, he simply walked across and passed.
After that, Milligan asks them to come with
him to the place where their final test
will be taken. He takes them to a sewer, claiming
that it is the pathway to reach their destination.
The kids find it odd that the entrance examination
to such a prestigious school makes the finalists
walk through sewage. Reynie also notes that none
of the examiners have mentioned the Boatwright
Academy yet. He still trusts Milligan and
follows him to reach the front lawn of a mansion.
Milligan leaves them alone for a few minutes
to check if everything is prepared inside. When
the kids are left to themselves, Dewey starts to
exercise while the other three talk about their
families. Kate reveals that her mother died when
she was a little girl and her father abandoned her
in an orphanage. She doesn’t blame him because
that is how she found her love for circuses.
Reynie also reveals that he never knew his parents
but he still misses them generally. Dewey follows
up with a comment saying that his parents love
him and call him their miracle. Following that,
they are called inside the mansion that looks
like a maze. Rhonda appears in front of them and
reveals that she was sent to test them. For their
next task, they are kept in four different parts
of the maze and are asked to find a way to reach
the second floor. Once they have climbed to the
said floor, the first three to ring the bell will
pass. As a hint, Rhonda mentions that they should
be able to do this with their eyes closed. The
task finally starts and Reynie immediately begins
looking for clues. He sees that each doorway has
four signs that point in different directions.
Meanwhile, Sticky takes the clue seriously and
tries to solve the maze with his eyes closed.
Because of his photographic memory, he
navigates the way pretty quickly.
Kate, on the other hand, thinks out of the box.
She opens a vent on the wall and uses it to
climb up. At last, there is Dewey who follows
Sticky around. When he reaches the stairs,
Dewey pushes him to the wall and rings the
bell before everyone. Reynie soon finds out
that the signs are in braille which tell him the
direction. He also reaches the stairs and helps
Sticky up. Kate is already there and is waiting
for them so they can all ring the bell together.
As they do, the three win, and Dewey
is disqualified. In the instruction,
it was said that “the first three to ring the bell
will win” because Sticky, Kate, and Reynie were
the three who rang it together, they won.
Following that, they are introduced to the
mastermind of the test Mr. Nicholas Benedict.
As they talk about further orientation,
the fourth and youngest member named Constance
joins their team. She is a small, intelligent,
and witty girl who doesn’t care about what anyone
thinks. It turns out that she passed the test
a bit differently than the others. First, she
crossed all the questions, claiming that they
were wrong, then, she disobeyed the instructions
and brought as many pencils as she wanted,
and in the last test, she enjoyed a
sandwich instead of solving the maze.
Her unique personality still got her selected.
Then, for the moment of truth, Mr. Benedict tells
them that they haven’t been recruited for
Boatwright Academy’s scholarship, instead,
they have been selected for an undercover
mission to save the world. The children
can hardly comprehend what is going on.
Mr. Benedict explains that they are the only
ones who can end “the emergency” and save the
world from chaos. It turns out that a mysterious
subliminal message is being broadcasted all
around the globe through radios and televisions.
When people listen to such TV and radio shows,
they only hear the sound that has the highest
frequency. But behind that sound, someone has
added violent messages in low frequency that
the human ear cannot catch. Although people cannot
hear the message, their brain reacts to frequency.
Hence, they subconsciously start to believe the
message which makes them anxious. These messages
have created the illusion of international
panic that we call "The Emergency".
After a year long research, Mr. Benedict has found
out that the signals of the messages are coming
from an island that is the home to a children’s
school. Hence, only kids are allowed to go there.
Therefore, their group has been selected for
the task. He gives them the option to say no
and is happy that he got to meet such intelligent
kids. After much thinking, all of them agree to
join the mission and start their training.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.